every time I see denzel's name on a
poster I'm tempted to scream it like a
middle-aged black woman dancing flight
stars Denzel Washington John Goodman and
Don Cheadle it's directed by Robert
Zemeckis the man who made us back to the
future Forrest Gump castaway and this is
finally his return to live action he's
been in a long run of motion capture
work Denzel Washington plays a pilot and
he successfully lands a plane that had
some equipment failure in mid-flight it
went into a nosedive and he was able to
pull this amazing trick and land it
safely few people died but the majority
of the people survived he was looked at
as a hero and everything but then an
investigation starts and they're
wondering was he sober when he was
flying was there any alcohol involved
what's going on here is this
manslaughter and it becomes this big
drama filled with a lot of tension and
characters that are so well realized I
think this is one of denzel's best
performances and that's saying something
this guy his Denzel Washington for
goodness sakes he's it's Denzel
Washington he's a great actor he's been
making movies forever and he's always
good and this is one of his best he is
excellent in this film he gives a really
nuanced performance it's a performance
that you can tell us holding back you
know some actors might be so tempted to
go over the top and the crying and the
screaming and everything and this guy he
holds it back and you can see it see
basically he plays an alcoholic pilot
you see this guy he's just breaking but
the pressure of people who see him
drinking and drinking and drinking and
you know this is not going well for this
guy and if he's gonna convince these
people that he was okay while he was
flying this plane he's gonna have to
beat this alcoholism thing and that's
really what this movie is about a lot of
people are gonna be disappointed by the
lack of intense flights action sequences
or whatever there's a great one in this
movie for sure the title flight says a
lot because it's not so much about you
know he's on a flight yes the flight
starts everything but it's really about
him fleeing from this problem he has
he's in a constant flight from his
problem of alcoholism
there isn't a director after who has the
style that
mecca's has he has this this really good
way of like introducing really intense
shots into a film and this strange
soundtrack this really eclectic
soundtrack that makes you feel like what
like it's just I don't know like certain
song choices in the movie just really
work for the film and the way Zemeckis
is able to string a story together that
tells a story throughout time is always
really impressive John Goodman is on
fire this year he was so good he was so
funny in Argo and his characters really
likable here too he plays this guy who
kind of helps Denzel out with various
supplies and things and he's just he's
really great in this movie he's really
entertaining as always he's an old pro
he's great in the film this is one of
those movies where you watch it and you
just you thinking to yourself like dude
don't take another drink like just stop
man you know you're not supposed to be
doing this right now you start talking
to him in your head like ah dude don't
tell you know a drink don't take all he
took another drink great I have one
major problem with this movie and it
really downgraded that film I thought
see there's a side story in this film
that kind of becomes integrated in the
whole main story of this girl she's a
drug addict and she runs in in Denzel
Washington and they sort of help each
other in ways I guess but there was an
aspect of the film that was kind of
boring me that I felt kept deviating and
I was trying to identify what it was and
I didn't really catch on to it until the
end of the film I didn't think that
character needed to be in this movie I
felt that she could have just been
removed from the entire movie actually I
understand you need Denzel to talk to
somebody and there were certain aspects
of what was going on between those
characters that was definitely there was
some meet there for sure I just felt
like it didn't really need to be in the
movie in the long run and I feel like
maybe if they remove that the movie
would have been a little more riveting
nevertheless I still really enjoyed this
film it's a film that's marvelously
acted it's one in denzel's best
performances for sure it's a great
welcome return for Zemeckis as a
director I'm excited to see what else
he's going to do I'm gonna give the film
a B+
it has a riveting finale for sure a
really heartfelt finale to that I
thought was just perfect a really great
send-off for the movie I enjoyed flight
a lot check it out when it comes out
thanks as always for watching guys and
if you like this and you can click right
here and get stuck my nice
[Music]